okay we have to talk to you because I
watched the first episode what did you
think it is so much darker than I
anticipated
just a little it's really dark and I
mean peach is completely different from
anything else I've ever played before so
I was excited for people to get to see
the character how's the fan reaction
been for you especially compared to
being a part of a show like PLL with
insane amazing fans it's been amazing I
think also too you know Penn's fans from
Gossip Girl and everything it's just a
lot of fans I'm coming together and
really being so supportive of you and
they love it so I'm super excited about
it like Penn Badgley character is not a
big fan of speech he's not an either his
be Japan and Penn characters so they
kind of go toe-to-toe but I mean that's
what makes it exciting throughout the
season this is just the beginning you
know on a rollercoaster when you just
start off this is the beginning you just
buckle your seatbelt you know about the
perfectionist they are filming I know I
can't wait to see the pilot episode of
it I'm so excited we're all gonna get
together and watch it together the whole
PLL cast yes we're gonna aim for that as
many people as we can gather together in
LA we are gonna try and get together and
thus in are we gonna see I feel like we
are gonna see some sort of Aniston
situation are you set to appear in any
capacity appear but I am super excited
to see the perfectionist so I can't wait
for it to air as the season goes on any
chance that we would know you never know
not playing as of now you never know
yeah how do you think it's gonna happen
to those twins oh my gosh I can only
imagine but you know what it's in really
really great hands with those writers so
it's going to be good whatever it is
[Music]
[Applause]